It's a question many of us have pondered. If I had been born somewhere else in another country, another community, another culture, would I be the same person? Would I think the same way? Would I see the world differently? Psychologists have long searched for universal truths about the human mind. But another growing area of research asks a different question. How much of what we think and perceived is shaped by the culture we grow up in. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies just that. What aspects of human development are consistent across cultures and what things vary? Can culture influence basic cognitive processes like visual perception and numerical reasoning, not just beliefs and values? How does culture shape children's cognitive development as they
这是一个许多人都思考过的问题。如果我出生在另一个国家、另一个社区、另一种文化的其他地方，我会是同一个人吗？我会用同样的方式思考吗？我会以不同的方式看待世界吗？长期以来，心理学家一直在寻找关于人类心灵的普遍真理。但另一个不断发展的研究领域提出了一个不同的问题。我们的思考和感知中，有多少是由我们长大的文化所塑造的。今天我们要采访一位专门研究这个问题的心理学家。人类发展的哪些方面在不同文化中是一致的，哪些事情会有所差异？文化是否能影响基本的认知过程，比如视觉感知和数字推理，而不仅仅是信念和价值观？文化如何塑造儿童在成长过程中的认知
grow? And how do children themselves help shape culture over time? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Dorsa Amir, an assistant professor of psychology and neuroscience at Duke University, where she leads the mind and culture lab. Her research explores how cultural environments shape the mind and how the mind in turn shapes culture.
发展？孩子们自己又是如何随着时间推移帮助塑造文化的？欢迎来到《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是杜克大学心理学和神经科学助理教授多尔萨·阿米尔博士，她在那里领导心灵与文化实验室。她的研究探讨了文化环境如何塑造心灵，以及心灵反过来如何塑造文化。
She's worked with children and adults across the world, including the Shuar people, and indigenous community in the Amazon. She's published dozens of articles in scientific journals, and her research and writing have been featured in media outlets, including The Washington Post, Slate, Eon, and Scientific American. Dr. Amir, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a couple of definitions.
她曾与世界各地的儿童和成人合作，包括亚马逊的原住民社区舒阿尔人。她在科学期刊上发表了数十篇文章，她的研究和写作也曾在《华盛顿邮报》、《Slate》、《Eon》和《科学美国人》等媒体上亮相。阿米尔博士，谢谢你今天能来参加我的节目。非常感谢邀请我。让我们从几个定义开始。
As I said, your work looks at how culture and cognition interact. How do you define those two terms, culture and cognition in your research? Wow, okay, big question, right? Those are very, very tough terms to define. I will say, you know, I have my working definition of those concepts. But one of the thing I often encourage people to do is to define their own versions of those concepts when they do their work. And some of my work has really been about having more precision in those definitions. So loosely speaking, I would say I define culture as essentially things that are the product of other people. So one canonical definition of it is about socially transmitted information. So stuff you have to learn from other people. I don't know if that's necessarily broad enough because there's lots of stuff that we're learning second or third hand from others. And of course, we're interacting with technologies and tools that other people have produced. So that's kind of my fuzzy definition of it. But I think it can vary quite a lot. And cognition similarly, that is quite a loaded question. What exactly is cognition
正如我所说，你的工作关注文化与认知如何互动。在你的研究中，你是如何定义“文化”和“认知”这两个词的？哇，好的，这是一个很大的问题，对吧？这两个词非常非常难定义。我想说，你知道的，我对这些概念有我自己的工作定义。但我经常鼓励人们做的一件事情，就是在他们做研究时，去定义他们自己版本的这些概念。我的一些工作实际上就是为了让这些定义更加精准。所以粗略地说，我将文化定义为本质上是其他人产物的事物。因此，它的一个经典定义是关于社会传递的信息。也就是你必须从其他人那里学习的东西。我不知道这是否足够广泛，因为我们有很多东西是从其他人那里通过第二手或第三手学到的。当然，我们也在与其他人生产的技术和工具进行互动。所以这可以说是我的一个模糊定义。但我认为它的差异可以相当大。同样，认知也是一个相当沉重的词。究竟什么是认知
and what are its constituent parts? There are people, for instance, that would argue that the way that we visually perceive the world and our knowledge and beliefs about the world are actually different parts of our mind and maybe dissociate between those two things. I don't necessarily have a dog in that fight, but I guess you could think about it as the way the mind functions, how it interacts with the world and what those input-output relationships look like. So very broad terms, I would say.
它的组成部分是什么？例如，有人会认为，我们视觉感知世界的方式以及我们对世界的知识和信念，实际上是我们心灵的不同部分，这两者之间可能会解离。我未必一定要卷入这场争论，但我想你可以把它看作是心灵运作的方式、它与世界互动的方式，以及输入与输出的关系是什么样的。所以我要说，这是非常广泛的术语。
Now, has psychology as a field spent a lot of time thinking about these questions or has it focused more on looking for universal aspects of cognition rather than how it varies across cultures? Well, I will say this is a very old question, this idea of how cultural influence and how the environment shape our minds. I think it's one of the oldest questions you can trace the history of this all the way back through diverse cultures and lineages throughout thousands of years. So it's certainly one we've been grappling with for a very long time. I think, in fact, the kind of modern renaissance that produced cognitive science in its more modern form really actually had cross-cultural studies and anthropology as one of the central foundational disciplines in this view of what cognitive science was. So I think there's long been a theoretical interest in the way that culture shapes the mind and vice versa.
那么，心理学作为一个领域，花了很多时间思考这些问题，还是更多地关注寻找认同的普遍方面，而不是研究它在不同文化中的差异？嗯，我要说这是一个非常古老的问题，关于文化影响和环境如何塑造我们心灵的想法。我认为这是最古老的问题之一，你可以把它的历史追溯到几千年来不同文化和世系的发展。所以这绝对是我们一直在长期探讨的问题。事实上，我认为产生现代认知科学的现代复兴，实际上确实将跨文化研究和人类学作为这种认知科学观点的核心基础学科之一。因此，我认为长期以来，人们一直对文化塑造心灵以及反之亦然的方式有着理论兴趣。
though I will say that the empirical work, there was a lot of it, certainly in the mid-20th century, it was really picking up a lot of steam. But then there was a series of essentially historical and epistemological accidents you could describe them as that fractured the field a bit. So my home field, I was initially trained in anthropology, adopted the four-field model, which has become emblematic of American anthropology, within which there's cultural, archaeology, linguistic and biological. And it really spans the entire, the world of methods is quite broad. So you go all the way from extremely qualitative, humanities-based inquiry, all the way to very quantitative. And so as a result of the changes that were happening within anthropology, I think this relationship between culture and
虽然我要说，实证工作确实有很多，特别是在20世纪中叶，它确实在积蓄大量势头。但随后发生了一系列本质上可以说是历史和认识论上的意外，导致这个领域有些分裂。因此，我最初接受人类学训练的本科学科采用了一种四领域模型，这已成为美国人类学的标志，其中包含文化、考古、语言和生物人类学。它的跨度确实非常广泛，整个方法论的世界相当宏大。所以你的研究可以从极度定性的、基于人文学科的探究，一直延伸到高度定量的研究。因此，由于人类学内部发生的变化，我认为文化与
cognition became less of a hot topic, so to speak. And I think there's been a revitalization of that effort in recent years. So certainly with the advent of, for instance, a very notable paper in BBS called the weirdest people in the world, this idea that the mind should be examined across cultural environments, I think, gained this second wind. So old question, some ups and downs historically, but I do think there is increased attention and energy in this subfield today. Now, you've been working since 2014 with a community in Ecuador called the sure. Tell us about that community, how has working with them shaped how you think about these questions of culture and cognition, and why the shua? Yeah, definitely. So the shuar are a hunter-horticulturalist
认知的关系变得不那么热门了，可以这么说。我认为近年来这种努力得到了复兴。当然，随着BBS上一篇非常著名的论文《世界上最怪异的人》的问世，即应该跨文化环境检查心灵的想法，我认为这获得了第二次生命。这是一个古老的问题，历史上经历了一些起伏，但我确实认为当今这个子领域受到了更多的关注和注入了更多活力。现在，你自2014年以来一直在与厄瓜多尔一个名为舒阿尔的社区合作。给我们讲讲这个社区，与他们合作是如何塑造你对文化与认知这些问题的看法的，以及为什么选择舒阿尔？是的，绝对的。所以舒阿尔人是一个猎人园艺师
group in the Ecuadorian Amazon, and they're one of many different groups around the world now that are still practicing what we call traditional subsistence practices. So they are hunting, gathering, cultivating garden crops and doing sometimes some small-scale agriculture. Now, what's notable about that is that the social structure and the daily activities of people and the ways the communities are organized have a very long tale in history. So I think a lot of those structures and interactions and practices are thousands, if not hundreds of thousands of years old. And so you kind of get to see what the human life is like in a structure that maybe
群体，生活在厄瓜多尔亚马逊地区，他们是现在世界上仍然在实践我们称之为传统生计方式的众多不同群体之一。因此，他们在进行狩猎、采集、耕种园地作物，有时还进行一些小规模农业。现在，值得注意的是，社会的结构、人们的日常活动以及社区的组织方式在历史上有很长的演变轨迹。因此，我认为其中许多结构、互动和实践拥有成百上千甚至数十万年的历史。因此，你可以看到人类生活在一个
resemble something very different than what someone in an industrialized society might experience. And so you can really start to tease apart what the role is of those kinds of social, ecological, and environmental factors in shaping some of the things that we're really interested in. So I've been working with the Choir and other communities that still practice some of these more traditional subsistence practices for a long time and, of course, through many collaborations with wonderful researchers all around the globe. And I've really learned a lot. I will say just in my initial experiences, spending some of my summers out, living among these communities, it really was quite a transformative experience, both personally and professionally, because I think you really get to step outside the culture that you are familiar with. And in both these subtle and more seriously and more explicit ways, start to question some of these assumptions that you might have about what life can be like or should be like. And so I think it really helped expand my view on what life could look like.
可能与工业化社会中的人所经历的截然不同的结构中是什么样子的。因此，你真的可以开始剖析这些社会、生态和环境因素在塑造我们真正感兴趣的一些事物方面所起的作用。因此，我和舒阿尔人以及其他至今仍在使用这些更传统的生计方式的社区合作了很长时间，当然，也通过与全球各地优秀研究人员的多次合作，我真的学到了很多。我可以说，仅在我最初的体验中，花了一些夏天在这些社区中生活，这确实是一次具有变革意义的经历，无论是在个人还是专业层面上，因为我认为你真的可以走出你熟悉的文化。以微妙的、更严肃的以及更明确的方式，开始质疑你可能对生活可以是什么样或应该是什么样的某些假设。因此，我认为它确实帮助拓展了我对生活样貌的看法。
And in particular, as you mentioned earlier, what something like childhood might look like. So one of the things that I've been quite interested in is how children develop across different cultures. And there are really some market differences between children growing up in these more foraging-based societies and what a child in a much more market-integrated industrialized society might experience. And I think seeing that in sharp contrast was really evocative and really interesting intellectually and really trying to understand what are some of the consequences of these changes across a relatively short span of time and what that means for cognitive development more generally. And what do you see? I mean, how do children in a culture like the Choir differ from kids you might meet in, you're at Duke?
特别是，正如你刚才所提到的，像童年这样的时期可能会是什么样子。因此，我一直相当感兴趣的一件事情是儿童在不同文化中的发展方式。在这些以采集为主的社会中长大的儿童与在更加市场整合的工业化社会中长大的儿童所经历的事情之间，确实存在一些显著的差异。亲眼看到这种鲜明的对比非常震撼，在智识上也极其有趣，而且这真的有助于理解在相对较短时间内这些变化的一些后果是什么，以及这对更广泛的认知发展意味着什么。你看到了什么？我的意思是，生活在像舒阿尔这样的文化中的孩子，与你在杜克大学可能会遇到的孩子有何不同？
I mean, right? Kids in North Carolina. Yeah, so I would say some big differences and some surprising similarities. So one of the things to note is that in a lot of these foraging-based societies, communities are smaller. So you have, you know, a number of households that all kind of know each other, sometimes they're kin, sometimes they're non-kin. But what you also have is a community of children kind of within the larger community of members. And because human are, you know, we are not seasonal breeders like some other primates, and so we have children all throughout the year. And really, as a function of just the number of people in the community and the fact that we, you know, can have children throughout the year, what you end up with are children of various ages. Very rarely do you have a cohort of kids that are exactly the same age in the same way that you might, for instance, in a second grade classroom. And so the first thing to note is that there are a lot of kids,
我的意思是，对吧？北卡罗来纳州的孩子们。是的，所以我想说，有一些巨大的差异，也有一些令人惊讶的相似之处。因此，需要注意的一点是，在许多这些以采集为主的社会中，社区规模更小。所以你有，你知道的，一定数量的家庭，他们都互相了解，有时他们是亲属，有时他们不是亲属。但你也会在更大范围的成员社区中拥有一个儿童社区。而且因为人类是，你知道的，我们不像其他一些灵长类动物那样是有季节性繁殖规律的，我们全年都有孩子。而且，由于社区中的人数以及我们可以在全年都有孩子这一事实，你最终得到的会是各种不同年龄的孩子。你很少能拥有一群年龄完全相同的孩子，不像你在二年级教室里可能会看到的那样。所以首先要注意的是，有很多孩子，
and they are of mixed ages. And actually, the further back you go in time, the more children there are. So this is one big change that's happened with the advent of things like industrialization is that the average family size has changed a lot. So you're going from a fertility rate of, let's say, five to seven kids per family, down to something like two or three. So there are more children. About 50% of the population, for instance, among the schwar and among,
而且他们年龄混合。事实上，你追溯到越早的时间，儿童的数量就越多。所以这是随着工业化等事物的出现而发生的一个重大变化，那就是平均家庭规模发生了很大变化。因此，你的生育率从比方说每个家庭5到7个孩子，下降到了大约2个或3个。所以有更多的孩子。例如，在舒阿尔人当中，大约50%的人口
you know, similar communities are under the age of 14. So it's a very young population of mixed ages. So that's just the demography, right? So just structurally very different, smaller population sizes, more children, more mixed ages. And the other thing that I think is quite interesting is the locus of control, I suppose you could describe it as, which is who gets to determine what children are doing on a day-to-day basis? Who is making those choices? And what you find is that for sure, in industrial settings, the daily activities that children participate in are largely adult created. So we kind of determine when school starts, for instance, what they do in that classroom. And there are periods, of course, and hopefully increasingly more in these settings where children
你知道的，类似的社区都在14岁以下。所以这是一个年龄混合的非常年轻的人口结构。所以这只是人口统计学上的特征，对吧？所以在结构上非常不同，人口规模更小，儿童更多，年龄更加混合。而我认为相当有趣的另一件事是控制点，我想你可以这样来描述它，也就是谁来决定孩子们日常在做什么？谁在做这些选择？你会发现在工业化环境中，孩子们参与的日常活动很大程度上是由成人设定的。因此，比如我们决定学校什么时候开始，他们在那个教室里做什么。当然，在这些环境中，也有一些时期，希望在这些环境中越来越多，儿童
have some autonomy to decide how to engage with things. But it's very, very different in terms of the amount of agency and autonomy granted when you look at children in some of these smaller-scale societies. And so typically they are deciding what they do on a daily basis. And most of the time what they're doing is assorting into peer groups. That's what they want to do. And this is, I think, one of the nice and really striking similarities, actually, is that that inherent motivation is still the same in societies like the United States.
拥有一定的自主权来决定如何与事物互动。但是当你审视其中一些较小规模社会的儿童时，在被赋予的主体性和自主权方面，情况有着非常非常大的不同。因此，通常他们自己决定日常做什么。而大多数时候他们所做的是融入同龄人群体。那是他们想做的事情。而且我认为，这是一个很好且非常显著的相似之处，实际上那种内在动机在像美国这样的社会中仍然是一样的。
That's still what kids want to do. But sometimes they have to get a bit more creative about how to do it. So maybe they see their friends on Minecraft, right? but they are still really strongly motivated to assort into what we call these peer groups and create what we refer to as pure culture. And so you really do see, again, in this direct comparison, what really stands out, some things that are quite distinct and different, but really you also see this underlying shared capacity and motivation that I think is quite striking.
这依然是孩子们想做的事。但有时他们必须在如何做到这一点上发挥更多的创意。所以也许他们在《我的世界》里看到他们的朋友，对吧？但他们仍然有着非常强烈的动机去融入我们所称的这些同龄人群体，并创造我们所指的同龄人文化。所以你确实看到，在这个直接的比较中，有些非常鲜明和不同的东西脱颖而出，但你也确实看到了这种潜在的共同能力和动机，我认为这相当惊人。
One of the experiments that I think you've run with the Shore Children is, to recreate Walter Michelle's famous marshmallow test. And you get a very different reaction from these children compared to the ones that we might see in the United States or westernized cultures. Can you talk about that? Yeah, absolutely. So this is some of my earliest empirical work was trying to test what some of these hallmarks of cognitive development look like across these very different ecologies. And one of the things I was really interested in were these preferences that are kind of at the heart of decision-making, So those related to time, like the one you're mentioning now. So how willing are you, for instance, to wait for more rewards in the future?
我认为你对舒阿尔儿童进行的一项实验是重新演绎沃尔特·米歇尔著名的棉花糖实验。与我们在美国或西方化文化中可能看到的儿童相比，你从这些儿童身上得到了非常不同的反应。你能谈谈那个实验吗？是的，绝对的。所以这是我最早的一些实证工作，试图测试认知发展的某些标志在这些截然不同的生态环境中是什么样子的。我真正感兴趣的事情之一是处于决策核心的偏好，所以那些与时间有关的偏好，就像你现在提到的那个。比如，你有多愿意为了未来的更多奖励而等待？
And I also looked at risk preferences. So how likely are you to take on risk, essentially? If I say you can have a candy guaranteed or you get a one in six chance of two candies, does that seem compelling to you? And what we find in the United States is that there tends to be this change across development where younger kids seem to be more present oriented. So they prefer things now. And they tend to be a bit more risk seeking. They're more exploratory. They take on risk.
我还研究了风险偏好。所以，本质上，你承担风险的可能性有多大？如果我说你可以保证得到一颗糖果，或者你有六分之一的机会得到两颗糖果，这对你来说有吸引力吗？我们在美国发现的是，在整个发展过程中似乎会发生这种变化，较小的孩子似乎更倾向于关注当下。所以他们现在就想要东西。而且他们往往更倾向于寻求风险。他们更具探索精神。他们会承担风险。
And this has kind of long been described as a signature of early childhood. But what you find actually when you look at communities like the shore, and this is the work that I conducted over a decade ago now, what you find is that there are differences actually based on what the local environment is incentivizing. So what you find is that kids that are living in these much more remote communities that are less market integrated, meaning they're less reliant on markets and infrastructure and urbanization for their subsistence. They're mostly, for instance, hunting and growing crops. They are actually pretty present-oriented, but they're also very risk-averse. And so you see this profile that's
这长期以来一直被描述为幼儿的一个特征。但当你审视像舒阿尔这样的社区时——这是我十多年前进行的研究——你实际发现的是，根据当地环境在激励什么，其实会存在差异。所以你发现，生活在这些更偏远、市场整合度更低的社区中的孩子，这意味着他们对维持生计的依赖较少依赖市场、基础设施和城市化。他们主要，例如，是在狩猎和种植农作物。他们实际上相当关注当下，但他们也非常规避风险。所以你会看到这样一种剖面，它是
kind of more generally risk-averse because waiting for tomorrow for something kind of carries some risk with it. You know, you have to kind of be willing to accept that I'll be there again tomorrow to return, you know, these rewards to you. And so there seems to be just this much more risk-averse decision profile. And what's really interesting is that when you compare those kids to Schwer kids that are still in Schwer communities, but just much closer to the cities, you start seeing a profile that looks a lot more like the American kids. And so those same patterns seem to be moderated by stuff like industrialization and market integration. And I think that casts a little bit of doubt on this idea that there is kind of a universal cognitive developmental timeline that
因为等待明天到来带来某种回报本身就具有一定风险，所以总体上更倾向于规避风险。你知道，你必须愿意接受明天我还会回到这里，把这些回报交还给你。因此，决策画像中似乎存在着更强烈的风险规避倾向。非常有趣的是，当你把这些孩子与那些仍然生活在希舒尔社区但距离城市更近的希舒尔孩子进行比较时，你会发现他们的行为画像看起来更像美国孩子。因此，这些相同的模式似乎受到工业化和市场整合等因素的调节。我认为这让人对这种观点产生了一丝怀疑，即存在一种普遍的认知发展时间线，
all children go through. And the argument that we try to make is that those types of preferences that are really shaped by the local incentive structure and the decisions that you're making based on what's available around you. So it doesn't seem to be the type of thing that's necessarily universal, but much more sensitive to the context. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Amir about how kids learn about fairness and cooperation in different cultures. This episode is brought to you by L'Oreal Group. Beauty is a powerful force that moves us.
所有儿童都会经历。我们试图阐述的观点是，这些类型的偏好实际上是由当地的激励结构以及你根据身边的可用资源所做出的决策塑造的。因此，这似乎不一定是那种普遍存在的现象，而是对环境高度敏感。我们将进行短暂的休息。休息回来后，我将与阿米尔博士探讨儿童在不同 cultures（文化）中如何学习公平与合作。本期节目由欧莱雅集团赞助播出。美是一种推动我们前行的强大力量。
That's why L'Oreal Group has built a business that is inclusive at its heart with 100% of its brands, championing diversity. With 25,000 professional opportunities for people under 30 worldwide and 54% of leading positions held by women, diversity is a strength that helps L'Oreal Group create the best beauty products for all people. Visit laurel.com to learn more. Hey, y'all's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if?
这就是为什么欧莱雅集团构建了一个以包容为核心的业务，其100%的品牌都致力于倡导多元化。欧莱雅集团在全球为30岁以下的人群提供25,000个职业发展机会，其中54%的领导岗位由女性担任，多元化是一种力量，帮助欧莱雅集团为所有人创造最好的美妆产品。访问laurel.com了解更多信息。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，与威弗（Wayfair）合作。你是否曾在网上订购过家具，然后心里想：如果……会怎样？
Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. More recently, you published a study that looked at how cooperation develops in children,
比如，如果它不结实怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你本该在威弗订购的。在威弗，没有“如果会怎样”，只有你喜爱的设计和你可以信赖的品质。访问Wayfair.ca。威弗，每种风格，每个家。最近，你发表了一项研究，探讨了合作在儿童群体中是如何发展的，
both in the U.S., in the Schwar children and several other cultures. Talk about that. did you find? Yeah, absolutely. So this is kind of our attempt to enter the social world, so to speak. So I'd been working on these preferences and these individual decisions for a long time. And I'd started thinking a lot more about social interactions because, you know, at the heart of it, the humans are an extremely social species. And we are very much reliant on other people for our success. And so one of the things I was really curious about is what those cooperative preferences look like. When we interact with other people, what are the types of preferences that are guiding
无论是在美国、希舒尔儿童还是其他几种文化中。聊聊这个吧。你们发现了什么？是的，绝对的。所以这可以说是我们试图进入社会世界的一种尝试。很长一段时间以来，我一直在研究这些偏好和这些个体决策。我开始更多地思考社会互动，因为你知道，从根本上说，人类是一个极具社会性的物种。我们的成功在很大程度上依赖于其他人。因此，我真正好奇的事情之一就是这些合作偏好是什么样子的。当我们与其他人互动时，引导这些决策的偏好类型是什么？
those decisions? And how are those the types of things that are also shaped by culture? And so we did a very similar exercise here, which was looking at the development of this type of decision across different cultures. We looked at kids in five different countries. And we gave them a battery of tasks that were related to social interactions. So for instance, we gave them a chance to either accept or reject a number of candies that was divided between them and another person. person. So let's say they got four candies, the other person got one. And then you get to decide, does that seem good to you? Do you want to enact that? In which case you can say yes, or you can say, no, no, maybe that's not fair. Reject it and nobody gets it. And so we really wanted to look at how these
这些偏好又是如何受到文化塑造的呢？因此，我们在那里做了一个非常相似的练习，即观察这种决策在不同文化中的发展。我们观察了五个不同国家的儿童。我们给他们做了一套与社会互动相关的任务。例如，我们让他们有机会接受或拒绝一定数量的糖果，这些糖果是在他们和另一个人之间分配的。比方说，他们得到了四颗糖果，另一个人得到了一颗。然后你来决定，这听起来对你公平吗？你想执行这个分配吗？在这种情况下，你可以说“好”，或者你可以说“不，不，也许这不公平”，拒绝它，然后谁也得不到。因此，我们真的很想看看这些
types of responses varied across cultures. And what you find are some interesting, again, similarities and differences. So again, teasing apart this idea of what's shared and what's not. What you find is that five-year-olds everywhere are pretty much the same. I have a five-year-old myself. I guarantee he would do this. You give him four, you give the other person one. He goes, that's great, right, accepts that. Because why would you say no to candy? And what you find is that kids everywhere at age five are basically making that same choice.
类型的反应在不同文化中是如何变化的。你发现的再次是一些有趣的相似之处和不同之处。因此，再次剖析什么是共有的、什么不是这一观点。你发现，五岁的小朋友在各地几乎都是一样的。我自己就有一个五岁的孩子。我向你保证他也会这么做。你给他四颗，给另一个人一颗，他会说：“太棒了！”对吧，欣然接受。因为你为什么要对糖果说不呢？你发现，各地五岁的孩子基本上都在做着同样的抉择。
It doesn't really matter if they're hunter-gatherers in the Amazon or American kids in Boston. They seem to be making very similar choices. But then what you find is that across this period of what we call middle childhood, so between, let's say, five and 12, you start getting kids. changing their mind a little bit. But interestingly, what they're doing is changing their mind in line with what the adults in each of those communities, which we also surveyed, are telling you is the normative thing to do. And so we actually asked other kids and we asked adults in each of those communities in person, hey, imagine you're given a context like this. You get four or the other person gets one. Should you accept or reject it? What's the right thing to do? And what you find is that there's actually a lot of disagreement in the adults in what the correct thing. is to do, right? So in, for instance, the United States, you have adults saying you should reject it. It's not fair to have more than someone else. But many of the shore adults are saying, yeah, accept it. Why would you throw it away? It just seems inefficient. And what you find is that
他们是亚马逊雨林的狩猎采集者还是波士顿的美国儿童，其实并没有太大区别。他们似乎在做出非常相似的选择。但随后你会发现，在我们所谓的儿童中期这一阶段，也就是比方说5岁到12岁之间，孩子们开始稍微改变他们的想法。但有趣的是，他们改变想法的方向与我们同样进行过调查的各个社区中的成年人所告知的规范做法是一致的。因此，我们实际上询问了那些社区中的其他孩子和成年人，嘿，想象一下你被赋予了这样的情境：你得到四个，另一个人得到一个。你应该接受还是拒绝？正确做法是什么？你发现，对于什么是正确做法，成年人之间其实存在很多分歧。
across this period of middle childhood, kids start trending toward what the adults are saying is the right thing to do. And so again, you see this really interesting balance of similarities. You see kind of the similar behaviors in early life. And then you see that the norm internalization process, then actually internalizing what the thing is, that their community endorses and actually behaving in line with that, takes a long time to develop, especially if it's costly. It's hard to say no to candy. But it's taking place approximately at the same timeline across every society that we looked at. So what we would take away from this is the culture is supplying the norms. So what should you do? And development is kind of continuing along this relatively consistent path where this period really seems to be this hot period for learning what those things are and bringing your behavior in line with those norms.
所以在这一儿童中期阶段，孩子们开始趋向于成年人所说的正确做法。因此，你再次看到了相似性的有趣平衡。你在早期生活中看到了相似的行为。然后你发现，规范内化过程——即真正内化他们的社区所认可的事物并据此行事——需要很长时间才能发展，特别是当这种行为需要付出代价时。对糖果说“不”很难。但在我们研究的每一个社会中，它大约都在相同的时间线上发生。因此，我们可以从中得出结论：文化提供了规范，即你应该做什么；而发展则沿着这条相对一致的路径继续推进，在这一时期，学习这些事物并将自己的行为与这些规范保持一致，似乎是一个关键的高峰期。
And so I think we were able to extract out really cool insights about what's the same and what's not and what that tells us about cognitive development more broadly. It makes intuitive sense that some higher order concepts such as cooperation could be shaped by culture. but you've also written about more basic aspects of cognition, things like perception, visual illusions, numerical reasoning. How can culture influence those processes? What a great question. Well, this is an open question, right? So what can culture influence and what doesn't it? And I think this is a great empirical and theoretical question. I think it's really at the heart of this conversation. So I totally agree with you that these what we call higher order. things. So things like social norms are exactly the types of things that you might expect vary across cultures, right? So I'm Persian. If you come to my house, you have to take your shoes off. I'm sorry. And, you know, my American hasn't had a long history of trying to understand why that would be the norms. So those are the types of things. You know, anyone who's traveled or has met anyone from
因此，我认为我们能够提取出非常酷的见解，了解什么是相同的、什么不是，以及这能告诉我们关于更广泛的认知发展的什么信息。一些更高阶的概念（如合作）可以由文化塑造，这在直觉上是说得通的，但你也撰文探讨过更基础的认知方面，比如感知、视错觉、数值推理。文化如何能影响这些过程？多么棒的问题。嗯，这是一个开放性的问题，对吧？文化能影响什么，不能影响什么？我认为这是一个绝佳的实证和理论问题。我认为这确实是这场对话的核心。所以我完全同意你的观点，这些我们所谓的更高阶的事物——比如社会文化规范——正是你可能预料到在不同文化中会有所差异的那类事物，对吧？我是波斯人。如果你来我家，你必须脱鞋。我很抱歉。而且，你知道，我的美国人并没有花很长时间去试图理解为什么这会是规范。所以这些就是这类事物。你知道，任何旅行过或见过其他文化中任何人的人，
other cultures understands that those things can vary. And I think the really interesting and complicated questions arise when we start digging deeper, where we say, well, what else? kid it do. And there's a very, I think, interesting debate, actually arising from right around the 20th century, the early 20th century and through the mid-20th century, that almost sounds like a dorm room conversation, you know, where it's like akin to do we see the same color red. And it has to do with visual illusions, as you mentioned. Now, there's a very famous visual illusion called the Mueller-Leyer allusion. And if you're listening, today I'll try to describe it. You have two lines of equal length, but the line on top has these
都明白这些事情可能会有所不同。而我认为，当我们开始深入挖掘时，真正有趣且复杂的问题就出现了，我们会问：“好吧，还有什么？”这里有一个非常有趣且正在兴起的辩论，大约始于20世纪初到20世纪中期，听起来几乎像是一场宿舍里的深夜聊天，你知道的，类似于我们看到的红色是不是同一个红色。这正如你所提到的，与视错觉有关。现在，有一个非常著名的视错觉，叫做缪勒-莱尔错觉（Mueller-Lyer illusion）。如果你正在收听节目，我今天会试着描述它。你有两条等长的线，但上面那条线的两端有
outward facing arrowheads. So imagine like two little arrowheads pointing to the center of the line, and the line below has the outward facing arrowheads. And what's interesting about this illusion is that even though the lines actually are the same length, the one with the outward facing arrowheads just appears longer. So you ask people this and they say, this one's longer, it just looks longer, it doesn't matter if I know they're the same length. I can't get rid of it. And this is actually at the heart, I think, of a very fascinating and longstanding debate about culture. And it really encapsulates these two really interesting bodies of work. So there's one body of work that says visual perception is this core thing that's happening.
朝外的箭头。想象一下，两个小箭头指向线条的中心，而下面那条线则有朝外的箭头。关于这个错觉有趣的地方在于，尽管这两条线实际上等长，但带有朝外箭头的线条看起来就是更长。当你问人们时，他们会说：“这条更长，它看起来就是更长，我知道它们一样长也没用，我无法消除这种感觉。”这实际上可以说是关于文化的一个非常迷人且历史悠久的辩论的核心，它完美地概括了这两个非常有趣的学术流派。其中一个流派认为，视觉感知是一个发生的核心过程。
And the fact that if you measure it and it's exactly the same length, you can't get rid of the illusion, that's the point. There is nothing, there's no knowledge or belief state and certainly cultural, let's say, experience. That can change the fact that it just appears this way. But there was another influential body of work, marshaled by Siegel at all in the mid-20th century, that argued the opposite. So they took this illusion to many different cultures, and they showed what appeared to be a lot of variation in this illusion across these societies. And so there is a mystery. There's a mystery here as to whether or not this is true is it true that vision can reach deep down into something that we would describe as a really core, low-level process, like the discrimination of length. And so what my colleague and I chest virus don't did across actually almost a decade of thinking and writing this, we tried to marshal the evidence in favor and against what we call the cultural byproduct hypothesis, the idea that culture actually changes how you see these types of visual illusions.
如果你去测量它，发现它们完全等长，而你却无法消除这种错觉，这就是关键所在。没有任何知识或信念状态，当然也包括文化经验，能够改变它看起来就是这个样子的事实。但还有另一个颇具影响力的学术流派，由20世纪中期的西格尔（Segal）等人领导，他们主张截然相反的观点。因此，他们将这种错觉带到了许多不同的文化中，并展示了这些社会中这种错觉似乎存在很大差异。因此，这里存在一个谜团。这里有一个谜团：视觉是否真的能深入到我们所描述的非常核心、低水平的过程中，比如对长度的辨别？我和我的同事切斯特·瓦克斯伯特（Chester Wax-man）在过去近十年里进行思考和写作的过程中，试图整理支持和反对我们所谓的“文化副产品假说”的证据，这个假说认为文化实际上改变了你如何看待这些类型的视错觉。
And what we argue is that it's probably not the case that culture is shaping our ability to, let's say, be susceptible to this illusion. and I'll just kind of throw at you a few little highlights of the evidence against it. So the first, for instance, is that humans are not the only one susceptible to this illusion. Actually, you can see the same illusion, for instance, among guppies and other animals. So first of all, it doesn't seem to be human specific. The other is that you can actually get this same illusion in a haptic version. So if I touch an embossed version of the illusion, I actually still feel the illusion, even though I'm not seeing it. So it doesn't even seem to be about vision.
我们的观点是，文化可能并没有塑造我们易受这种错觉影响的能力。我只想向大家抛出几个反对这一假说的证据亮点。首先，人类并不是唯一易受这种错觉影响的物种。实际上，你可以在孔雀鱼和其他动物身上看到同样的错觉。所以首先，它似乎并不是人类所特有的。其次，你实际上可以在触觉版本中体验到同样的错觉。如果我触摸该错觉的浮雕版本，我实际上仍然会感觉到这种错觉，即使我没有看到它。所以它甚至似乎与视觉无关。
And the last one is quite interesting, the idea that, you know, so the cultural argument was that the types of environments that you're exposed to kind of form these visual habits. And so if you see a lot of, let's say, carpentry that has these sharp angles that look like the arrowheads, that actually produces the illusion. And so it really is about kind of cultural experience during visual development. But what you find in this really remarkable study where this humanitarian effort went out to correct congenital cataracts in children. So these are children that had not seen for their life because they were born with dense cataracts, but they're reversible. And so this humanitarian effort went out
最后一个相当有趣，即文化论点认为你所处的环境类型形成了这些视觉习惯。因此，如果你看到大量具有这些尖锐角度（看起来像箭头）的木工制品，这实际上就会产生这种错觉。所以它确实与视觉发展过程中的文化经验有关。但在这项非常引人注目的研究中，人道主义救援努力去矫治儿童的先天性白内障。这些儿童由于生来就患有严重的白内障而一生未曾看见光明，但这种白内障是可以治愈的。因此，这项人道主义救援努力出发了，
to fix those cataracts. And then as part of the assessment of visual acuity, they showed them illusions like the Mueller-Layer. And what you find is that they are susceptible to the illusion. And so it seems to not even require past visual experience per se. So I think that's just an example, you know, of the type of research endeavor to try and adjudicate these types of questions, which is like what are the types of things that culture really can penetrate versus not? You said earlier, you started out as an anthropologist with a PhD in evolutionary anthropology. How did you move from that field to working in a psychology department? And does having both of those perspectives influence the questions you ask? Yeah, absolutely. So my background is in
去修复那些白内障。作为视觉敏锐度评估的一部分，他们向这些儿童展示了诸如缪勒-莱尔错觉之类的错觉。你发现他们仍然容易受到这种错觉的影响。因此，它似乎甚至不需要本身的过去视觉经验。所以我想这只是一个例子，展示了试图裁决这些类型问题的研究工作，即文化真正能够渗透的领域与不能渗透的领域的区别。你之前说过，你最初是一名人类学家，拥有进化人类学博士学位。你是如何从那个领域转到心理学系工作的？拥有这两种视角是否会影响你提出的问题？是的，绝对的。所以我的背景是
biological and evolutionary anthropology because I was really, you know, captivated by the idea of human variation, human evolution, and just the really fascinating ways in which we have evolved things like culture to be able to live across every terrestrial ecology on the planet. Like, we live everywhere. How do we pull this off? So I started my PhD in biological anthropology, but I was always really interested in behavior. And what I really appreciated about the anthropological perspective is that culture was really always at the center, this idea that things like subsistence, whether you are hunting or gathering or farming, really have these important influences on the types of social experiences and behaviors and preferences
生物与进化人类学，因为我真的被人类变异、人类进化以及我们进化出诸如文化等事物以能够在地球上的每一个陆地生态系统中生存的迷人方式所深深吸引。我们无处不在。我们是怎么做到的？所以我开始了生物人类学的博士研究，但我一直对行为本身很感兴趣。我非常赞赏人类学视角的一点是，文化始终处于核心地位，即诸如生计方式——无论你是狩猎、采集还是农耕——对你所产生的社会经验、行为、偏好以及
and culture that you produce, that was really central. But I was always interested in behavior and psychology as well. And what I noticed in psychology is that it was really, I think, quite interesting in that it was looking at cognition itself from this perspective of what are actually the mechanisms, when information comes in, what's actually going on in this black box to produce this output. And what I found there was actually that the conversation around culture was still kind of emerging. And I really felt that that was a good intellectual home and that what I was most interested in is kind of what's going on in the mind. But the piece of culture and the role that it played seemed to be less developed. And so I really thought I could make a bigger impact
文化有着重要影响，这一观点确实是核心。但我同时也对行为和心理学感兴趣。我在心理学中注意到的是，它真的非常有趣，它从“当信息输入时，黑箱中到底发生了什么来产生这种输出”的机制视角来审视认知本身。我在那里发现，围绕文化的讨论实际上才刚刚兴起。我真的觉得那是一个很好的知识归宿，而我最感兴趣的是心灵中正在发生的事情。但是文化的成分及其所扮演的角色似乎没有得到充分的发展。所以我真的认为我可以产生更大的影响，
and find a good community and home for my work in psychology, which I think I've been able to do. It's a bit of a risky gamble, I think, to be truly interdisciplinary. It kind of feels a bit like being bicultural, which I also am, you know, or like, am I American, am I Persian? It's a little bit of both. And so I had to kind of become a dual citizen, so to speak, in anthropology and psychology. And it took a while, I think, to really become fluent, you know, in those languages and those cultures. But now that I have done it, I genuinely appreciate the insight that it gives me into both bodies of knowledge. I think there's a lot of room in between disciplines that is less excavated. And I think there's a lot to uncover there.
并为我在心理学领域的工作找到一个很好的社区和归宿，我想我已经做到了。我认为，跨学科是一场略带风险的赌博。它感觉有点像双重文化，我也是这样，你知道的，我是美国人还是波斯人？两者都有那么一点。因此，我不得不可以说是成为了人类学和心理学的双重公民。我认为，要真正精通那些语言和文化需要花费一些时间。但现在我已经做到了，我由衷地感谢它赋予我深入了解这两种知识体系的洞察力。我认为学科之间有很大的空间尚未被充分挖掘。我认为那里有很多东西有待发掘。
And so it was a little bit of a risky strategy, but I found it quite intellectually fulfilling. And I've really, I think, found a great home in psychology. And I think psychology in general has been very receptive to this approach. And likewise, I think anthropology has been very receptive. similarly welcoming. So I think in general, it's been a very positive endeavor. Well, given that background and the research you're doing, you're clearly pushing psychological research beyond weird societies. And for our listeners, just so they understand, that means Western, educated, industrialized, rich, and democratic, weird. But since most psychological
因此，这虽然是一个有点冒险的策略，但我发现它在知识上非常充实。而且我认为我在心理学中找到了一个非常好的归宿。我认为心理学界普遍对这种方法非常接受。同样，我认为人类学也非常欢迎这种方法。所以总的来说，这是一个非常积极的尝试。好吧，鉴于这种背景以及你正在进行的研究，你显然在将心理学研究推向超越“威德”（WEIRD）社会的范畴。为了我们的听众能够理解，这意味着西方、受过教育、工业化、富有且民主的社会（WEIRD）。但既然大多数心理学
research up until now is biased toward weird samples, do you think the body of research is wrong? Great question. So I thought about this a lot. So I don't think the body of research is wrong. So I don't think what I'm saying is no, but. I think what I'm saying is yes and. So I think we have great knowledge about how, for instance, children develop in industrialized societies. We have a lot of insights that we can leverage to create great environments for learning and at home for children, for instance. But I stopped short of saying, well, and that can automatically be exported out to every child on the planet. because I'm not sure that's true. And I think that there's just a lot to gain here in addition to what we already know in trying to both stress test some of our theories that we think may be universal, but we don't actually know. But also just this idea that, so, you know, kind of challenging and examining long-held assumptions, for instance, about things that are assumed to be universal. I think that's one very useful application of cross-cultural work. But also this other application, I find much more generative, which is, well, what can cultural diversity tell us about cognitive
一直以来的研究都偏向于奇特（WEIRD）的样本，你认为以往的研究主体都错了吗？这是个好问题。所以我对此思考了很多。我不认为研究主体是错的，我也不认为我的观点是否定的，而是“不仅如此”。我认为我们拥有丰富的知识，例如了解工业化社会中的儿童是如何发育的。我们有许多洞察可以利用，以此为儿童在学习以及家庭环境中创造良好的环境。但我不会盲目地说，这些知识可以自动推广到地球上的每一个儿童身上，因为我不确定这是否正确。我认为，除了我们已经知道的之外，还有很多值得探索的地方，我们可以去对那些我们以为是普遍存在、但实际上并不确定的理论进行压力测试。此外，这种观点还具有挑战和审视长期以来关于普遍性假设的意义，例如那些被假定为普遍存在的事务。我认为这是跨文化研究的一个非常有用的大方向。但另一个方向我发现更具启发性，那就是：文化多样性能告诉我们关于认知多样性的什么？
diversity? What can we gain? So in addition to kind of what we know, how can we understand what else is happening, right? What is variable and what is not? And what is growing up in all these different environments get you? What are the things that are malleable and what are the things that are less flexible? And so I find it to be a really exciting, you know, addition. And I certainly don't see it as an addendum. So I don't want to be in there like, you know, there's a citation and then you go, but see a mirror at all who found that this wasn't universal. You know, I think there's a lot more we can do beyond just testing assumptions of universality because culture offers us almost like a natural experiment laboratory. Like you can go out and find variation and ask really
我们能收获什么？所以，除了我们已知的东西，我们如何理解其他正在发生的事情？什么是可变的，什么不是？在所有这些不同的环境中长大能带给你什么？哪些是具有可塑性的，哪些又是相对固定的？我发现这是一个非常令人兴奋的补充，我绝对不认为它只是一个附录。我不希望它变成这样：某个地方有一句引用，然后你却说，但查看阿米尔等人的研究发现这并不是普遍的。你知道，除了测试普遍性的假设之外，我们还可以做更多的事情，因为文化几乎为我们提供了一个自然实验实验室。你可以走出去寻找差异，并提出真正尖锐且有趣的问题，探讨超越泛化性的人类认知。
pointed and interesting questions about human cognition beyond just does it generalize. To switch gears, I want to talk about a Twitter thing. thread you published a few years ago on things parents don't have to worry about, which sparked a little online debate. Can you talk about that connection to your research? Are there other broader practical lessons you think people, especially parents, should take from your research and maybe explain what it is that parents don't have to worry about? Yeah. Well, I will say, there's a lot to worry about as a parent. I'm a parent myself. I have a five-year-old, and now I have a fraternal twin, one-year-olds, by the way, which is a psychologist dream, really, because I'm running my own
话锋一转，我想聊聊你几年前在推特上发布的一个主题帖，关于父母不必担心的几件事，这在网上引发了一些小小的辩论。你能谈谈这与你的研究有什么联系吗？你认为人们，尤其是父母，从你的研究中还能得出哪些更广泛的实用经验？也许可以解释一下父母究竟不用担心什么？好吧，我得说，作为父母，有很多事情需要担心。我自己也是个父母。我有一个五岁的孩子，现在还有一岁异卵双胞胎，顺便说一句，这简直是心理学家的梦想，因为我正在进行我自己的自然与教养实验。
nature-nurture experiment. By the way, genes matter a lot, it turns out. But I think both those personal experiences of trying to navigate parenthood, you know, in the United States, which is where I live, but also having access to what parenting and what childhood could look like across cultures, I think, has really alleviated some of my anxiety. So, for instance, right now, I have, for maternal twins, one of them, they're both 15 months, one of them is walking and has been walking for three months. One of them has yet to walk. And I feel that under, you know, normal circumstances, a very well-intentioned parent might see that and be concerned. And I totally understand that. At the same time, you can contextualize that among the broader spectrum of variability, for instance,
顺便说一句，事实证明基因真的很重要。但我认为，这两方面的个人经验——一方面是在美国（我居住的地方）摸索育儿之路，另一方面是接触到跨文化中育儿和童年可能呈现的不同面貌——确实减轻了我的部分焦虑。举个例子，现在我的异卵双胞胎15个月大了，其中一个在三个月前就会走路了，而另一个还不会走。我认为在正常情况下，一个非常出于好意的父母看到这一幕可能会感到担忧，我完全理解这一点。但与此同时，你可以将这种现象放在更广泛的变异光谱中去理解，例如像走路这样的里程碑，
in milestones like walking, where, for instance, we know that in some cultures where walking is highly encouraged. So among the hans, for instance, they hold their babies up as much as they can so they can get their legs strong because they're a mobile group versus you have populations like the Aceh that are in the rainforest. They actually don't want them to walk because they don't want them to wander off. And so they discourage it. And those types of things really do have impact on when children walk. And so knowing that there's a lot of both genetic and cultural variability in that really calms me down, frankly. And I'm like, well, we're probably somewhere within the range of normal, you know. And so just being able to see how much variation there is.
我们知道在某些鼓励走路的文化中。例如在汉族，他们会尽可能地把婴儿托着，好让他们的腿变强壮，因为他们是一个需要经常移动的群体；而在热带雨林中的阿切族（Aceh），情况则相反。他们实际上不希望孩子走路，因为不想让他们到处乱跑，所以他们会阻止孩子走路。这些因素确实会影响孩子开始走路的时间。因此，了解基因和文化在这方面都存在很大的变异性，坦白说，这让我冷静了很多。我想，好吧，我们大概只是处于正常范围内。所以，只要能看到存在着这么多的变异，
And, you know, most kids become bipedal. When they start walking earlier or a little bit later, does it make them slow walkers or super walkers? Everyone becomes bipedal to some degree. And so just knowing those types of things I find quite comforting. And being able to contextualize American parenting and American childhood within the larger kind of evolutionary and cross-cultural picture, I have found very, really, illuminating. And I think a lot of these micro decisions that we're often concerned about. And again, it's well-intentioned. We want the best for our kids. I think in the big picture really wash out. And I find that a lot of my friends and colleagues, you know, there's a lot of pressure to be the
而且，大多数孩子最终都会学会双足行走。他们是走得早一点还是晚一点，会让他们变成慢走者还是超级走路达人吗？每个人在某种程度上都会学会双足行走。所以，了解这些事情让我感到相当宽慰。能够将美式育儿和美式童年置于更大的人类进化和跨文化图景中，我发现这真的非常有启发意义。我认为我们常常关心的许多微小决定——再次说明，这都是出于好意，我们都希望把最好的给孩子——从宏观角度来看，其实根本算不上什么。我发现我的许多朋友和同事，都有成为完美父母的巨大压力。
perfect parent. And there's a lot of pressure to monitor and set them up for success. And I completely understand that. But my general takeaway, honestly, is that most people are probably doing a good job. If you care about your kids, you know, the fact that you're asking me this question, for instance, is already revealing that you're an engaged parent who cares about your child's well-being. And a lot of the, you know, a lot of the outcomes that we care about, I think that's a pretty good predictor of it. And, you know, the other part truly is that, like, you as a parent are also a human being, you know, and there are costs and benefits to you. And you do need to think about yourself. The family is this, you know, it has to be in some degree of harmony. And so if you find yourself really anxious and really upset about some of the choices
并且有很多压力要去监督他们并为他们的成功做好准备。我完全理解这一点。但我总的切身体会其实是：大多数人可能都做得很好。如果你关心你的孩子，你问我这个问题这个事实本身，就已经表明你是一个关心孩子福祉的投入型父母。而我们关心的许多结果，我认为这是一个相当不错的预测指标。另一个事实是，作为一个父母，你首先也是一个活生生的人，这样做对你自身是有成本也有收益的。你确实需要考虑一下自己。家庭必须达到某种程度的和谐。所以，如果你发现自己因为某些可能在未来产生微小影响、也可能不会产生影响的选择而感到极度焦虑和不安，
that maybe will have a tiny effect down the road, maybe not. You know, I would encourage you to think also about your own experience of that decision. And, you know, it's a little, it's probably fine, is my general takeaway. It's probably fine. Well, I love that you said it's okay for kids to be bored. It's not parents' responsibility, right, to keep your kids entertained all the time. Oh, my gosh, yes. I am actually quite a boring parent, I will say.
也许吧，我鼓励你也思考一下自己对那个决定的体验。你知道的，这大概没问题，这就是我的总体看法。这大概没问题。我很喜欢你说的“允许孩子感到无聊”这句话。让孩子一直有事情做、保持娱乐，这不是父母的责任对吧？哦，天哪，是的。其实我是一个挺无聊的父母，我得承认。
So here's, by the way, talking about the demographic changes that have happened. So children, for a very long time, for basically all of human history, interact with other kids. That's what they do. And in fact, they want to run off with other kids in every situation they can find. One of the things that I feel it's happened as a result of these demographic changes is that children are around other children less. and they have less interactions. They have much more interactions with adults than ever before in human history, essentially.
所以，顺便谈谈所发生的人口结构变化。很长一段时间以来，基本上在整个人类历史上，孩子们都会与其他孩子互动。这就是他们所做的。事实上，他们在能找到的任何情况下都想和其他孩子一起跑开。我觉得人口结构变化带来的结果之一，就是孩子们和其他孩子在一起的时间变少了，他们的互动也减少了。与人类历史上的任何时期相比，他们现在与成年人的互动要多得多。
And what that creates is this really interesting, quirky thing, which is that adults are kind of, in order to interact with their kids, kind of take on a childlike mentality. So they will kind of become their zany, play a friend, and play pretend with them the way other children would do. But the problem is I'm an adult. Number one, I'm not good at it. And number two, I don't particularly enjoy it.
这就产生了一种非常有趣、奇特的情况：成年人为与孩子互动，往往会带有一种孩子气的思维方式。所以他们会变得有点疯狂，扮演玩伴的角色，像其他孩子一样陪孩子玩假扮游戏。但问题是，我是一个成年人。第一，我不擅长这个；第二，我其实并不怎么享受这个。
And so what I try to do as much as possible is get the kids. kids together because I just think that my, like, I'm not good on it. And every time I try to pretend something with my five-year-old, he tells me I'm doing it wrong anyway. So, you know, why am I bothering? But I think, you know, there's a lot of pressure to be, you know, be like their zany playfriend. And the other thing, you know, that I want to mention is that I think we have this conceptualization of a perfect childhood as one that is always positive. Like we, we, we, there are no negative experiences. They're not bored. They're entertained. They're learning. all the time. They're really happy. And I think those are good goals. But I also think that that's not
所以我尽量让孩子们聚在一起，因为我觉得，第一我在这方面不在行，而且每次我试图和五岁的儿子玩假扮游戏时，他都会指出我做得不对。所以，我何必自讨没趣呢？但我认为，社会上有很大的压力要求你成为那种疯狂的玩伴。另一件我想提及的事是，我认为我们对完美童年的概念化，是那种永远积极向上的童年。好像我们没有任何负面体验，他们不会无聊，他们一直都有娱乐，他们一直在学习，而且一直都很高兴。我认为这些都是好目标。但我也认为这并不一定就是生活的全部，对吧？我的生活也不是那样的。消极事物的缺失并不一定就能让某事变得完美。
necessarily what life is like, right? Like my life is not one. The absence of negative things is not necessarily the thing that makes something perfect. And so things like friction and boredom and even conflict, I think, are actually extremely important. They are formative experiences for children to really internalize and understand things like social interactions. So I can tell my child not to cut in front of someone in the line of the slide until my, you know, I lose my voice. But until he gets cut in line and knows what that feels like, maybe he doesn't have this deep appreciation for why that rule exists in the first place, right? Like, there is so much to learn from the ups and downs of day to day life that I don't think are bad per se. And so obviously,
因此，摩擦、无聊甚至冲突等事情，我认为实际上极其重要。它们是儿童内化和理解社交互动等事物的形成性体验。我可以一遍又一遍地告诉我的孩子在滑梯排队时不要插队，直到我嗓子哑了。但直到他自己被人插队并亲身体验到那种感觉之前，他可能无法深刻理解为什么这条规则一开始就存在，对吧？从日常生活的起起落落中，有太多东西可以学习，我并不认为这些本身就是坏事。所以很明显，
we want to avoid the big negative things, right? We want to provide a, a nourishing and safe environment for our children. That is, I think, 100% the right goal. But I'm much more tolerant, perhaps, as a parent and a scientist, of the little perturbations of day-to-day life, even when I get frustrated or I have an argument with my partner. I think it's okay for those things to exist because those things do exist in the world. And what I can model is kind of how to repair it and how I talk about the narrative of what I experienced. And, you know, I think giving children access to the real world, in age-appropriate ways, I don't think is a bad thing.
我们想要避免重大的负面事件，对吧？我们希望为孩子们提供一个滋养且安全的环境。我认为这100%是正确的目标。但作为父母和科学家，我对日常生活中的那些小波折更加宽容，甚至当我感到沮丧或与伴侣争吵时也是如此。我认为这些事情存在是正常的，因为这些事情在现实世界中本来就存在。我能做的是为他们树立榜样，展示如何去修复关系，以及我是如何用语言来描述我所经历的事情的。而且，我认为以适合年龄的方式让孩子们接触真实世界，并不是一件坏事。
So just to wrap up, what's next for you? What are you working on now? What do you hope to work on in the future? Lots of fun things going on in the lab right now that I've been setting up here. I will say one of the things that you mentioned has become increasingly an interest of mine, which is this idea of peer cultures. So I mentioned that children assort into these peer groups and they love spending time with their friends.
那么总结一下，你接下来有什么打算？你现在在研究什么？你希望未来研究什么？实验室里现在正在进行很多有趣的事情，这些是我最近一直在筹备的。我可以说，你刚才提到的其中一点已经越来越成为我的兴趣所在，那就是同伴文化的概念。我提到过儿童会自动归入这些同伴群体中，并且他们非常喜欢和朋友们在一起。
they actually don't want adults involved at all, frankly, and this seems to be a cross-cultural universal. And the question we can ask is, why are they doing this? And there's one version of it, and one version of childhood more generally, which is that children are kind of there to learn. And this is the, I think, canonical view of children. They need to learn about things. They're copying us. They're great imitators. They're sophisticated emulators. And it's all about kind of the receiving of cultural information. And some people have argued that childhood is really long in the human species to allow for learning, which is true. But I feel like there's a little bit more to the story, and I think it's related to what kids are doing in their little peer groups. So my colleague,
坦白说，他们实际上根本不想让成年人介入，而且这似乎是一个跨文化的普遍现象。我们可以提出的问题是：他们为什么要这样做？关于这一点有一种看法，也是对童年的更普遍的一种看法，即儿童到这里来主要是为了学习。我认为这是关于儿童的经典观点。他们需要了解事物，他们在模仿我们，他们是出色的模仿者和复杂的效仿者，这一切都与接受文化信息有关。有些人认为，人类物种的童年之所以很长，是为了给学习留出时间，这确实是真的。但我觉得事情并非这么简单，我认为这与孩子们在小同伴群体中所做的事情有关。所以我的同事香农·利维（Shannon Levy）和我最近发表了一篇文章，
Shannon Lev Levy and I recently published an article outlining this idea that maybe what they're doing is a lot more important and sophisticated than we're giving them credit for. Because we think in their peer groups, They are not just playing and socializing, but they are actually producing culture. There's actually a term we borrow from sociology called peer culture, and it's the body of cultural information generated and transmitted between children. And you might think of your own experiences of pure culture, for instance, in the West, is like little playground games or, you know, little hand-clapping games or rhymes or whatever. And that's true. Like I think a lot of the peer culture in West encompasses these things about play. But we did this broader analysis of peer culture,
阐述了这样一种观点：也许他们在做的事情比我们给予的认可要重要得多、复杂得多。因为我们认为在他们的同伴群体中，他们不仅在玩耍和社交，而且实际上还在生产文化。我们从社会学中借用了一个术语叫做“同伴文化”，它是儿童之间生成和传播的文化信息主体。你可能会想到自己在西方经历过的同伴文化，例如小操场游戏、拍手游戏、顺口溜等等。这确实没错，我认为西方许多同伴文化确实包含这些关于游戏的内容。但我们对同伴文化进行了更广泛的分析，
and what you find is that in a lot of other societies, especially these foraging societies, it is much more complex and much broader than that. Children have lots of cultural information, for instance, about how to forage for food, they target different game, they make their own material culture, they pick up the social and linguistic conventions of groups around them. They're much more exploratory. And one thing that we're arguing is that this kind of exploratory and distinct culture is actually really important in the history of cultural evolution, because it can help us as a whole community adapt when environments change. So as an adult, you're maybe setting your ways, you're doing things that you've probably been doing for 20 years.
你会发现，在许多其他社会中，尤其是这些以采集为生的社会，情况要复杂得多，也广泛得多。儿童拥有大量的文化信息，例如关于如何采集食物、他们会锁定不同的猎物、他们会制造自己的物质文化、他们会吸收周围群体的社会和语言习俗。他们的探索性要强得多。我们的一个观点是，这种探索性和独特的文化在文化进化的历史上其实非常重要，因为当环境发生变化时，它能够帮助整个社群进行适应。作为一个成年人，你可能已经墨守成规，做着你可能已经做了20年的事情。
Lord knows I'm already at the point now where I can't adopt new technologies. I'm done. You know, but my kids can pick it up really quickly. And we think there's something really profound going on there, which is that as an entire unit, the huge. human community. Children and their peer groups are playing a really interesting role in the generation and evolution of cultural knowledge in a way that I don't think they had been recognized for yet. So a lot of the questions, both empirically and theoretically, that we've been grappling with, are about this. Like, what, how do peer cultures change across time? What do they contribute to the whole community? And more generally, are we undervaluing and underappreciating children's
天知道我已经到了无法适应新技术的阶段了。我放弃了。你知道的，但我的孩子们可以非常快地学会。我们认为其中正在发生一些非常深刻的事情，也就是说，作为一个整体单元，这个庞大的人类社群中，儿童及其同伴群体在文化知识的生成和进化中发挥着非常有趣的作用，这种作用在过去还没有得到应有的认可。因此，无论是实证上还是理论上，我们一直在努力解决的许多问题都与此有关。比如：同伴文化随时间是如何变化的？它们对整个社群有什么贡献？更广泛地说，我们是否一直在低估和看轻儿童在人类历史中所扮演的角色？
roles in the human story? Well, that's all great information, and I look forward to seeing more of your research. Dr. Amir, I want to thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me on. This is wonderful. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org.
好吧，这些都是很棒的信息，我也期待看到你的更多研究。阿米尔博士，我想感谢你今天能来参加节目。谢谢邀请我来。这太棒了。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学对话》节目。如果你喜欢我们的话，请关注我们并留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology@APA.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Spotify, it's Jay Shetty. Are you one of those media strategy people? scrolling through spreadsheets, searching for an audience that pays twice as much attention to your ads than they do on social? Let me introduce you to fans. And they're here with me on Spotify.
《心理学对话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。Spotify，我是杰·谢蒂（Jay Shetty）。你是那种浏览电子表格、寻找对你的广告的关注度是社交媒体两倍的受众的媒体策略专家吗？让我为你介绍粉丝。他们和我一起在 Spotify 上。
Trust me, I know fans. They don't skip. They stay for hours. They don't move on, they manifest. They're not a demographic group. They're fans. Spotify advertising. You're among fans. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，我了解粉丝。他们不会跳过广告。他们会驻留数小时。他们不会移情别恋，他们会把愿望变成现实。他们不是一个人口统计群体。他们是粉丝。Spotify 广告。你正身处粉丝之中。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。